What happens when a Syrian refugee,
an Israeli aid worker
and an American Jew walk into a room?
(Laughter)
No, this is not the start
of a really bad joke, I promise.
This actually happened to me.
Starting in 2015,
I found myself holding
a series of secret meetings
in various European capitals
with a small group of Syrian
and Israeli civilians.
And we were there to try and figure out
how we can get aid to the Syrian people
who were enduring the worst
humanitarian crisis since World War II.
But how did we end up
at this table together?
After all, Syrians and Israelis
are sworn enemies,
and technically they've been
in a state of war since 1948.
Yet here we were,
literally and figuratively,
trying to find a way in.
And here is the punchline of that bad joke
I promised not to tell.
We found it.
We figured out a way to get aid
into Syria through Israel.
Now how did we do that?
I applied a three-step process
that I've used
in a bunch of other settings,
and I'm hoping that those three steps
will be useful to any of you
who want to do some good
in the face of any of the myriad
overwhelming conflicts
that we're facing today,
including Ukraine.
So what are my three steps?
Find an entry point,
identify a gap,
and then find something doable
with which to fill that gap.
It sounds pretty simple, right?
So let me walk you through it.
When I read a report on the Syrian war,
it hit me very hard
and it felt very personal.
I was stunned by the scale of the misery,
and it echoed the suffering
of my own family during the Holocaust.
My parents survived concentration
camps in Poland and in Hungary,
and after the war, we had to flee
and we arrived in the US
as stateless refugees.
So when I saw the destruction of Aleppo,
I was put in mind of Budapest,
the city of my birth,
the bombed out city of my birth.
And when I read about starvation
by siege in Syria,
I remembered my own mother
who lost a pregnancy lugging a sack
of rotten potatoes home
because there was nothing else to eat.
And when I saw the eviscerated
and emaciated corpses of Syrians
who had been tortured in Damascus prisons,
I also saw the walking
skeletons of Auschwitz,
Mauthausen and Bergen-Belsen,
where so many of my own family members
literally went up in smoke.
And when I saw Syrian refugees
flooding across borders,
I also recalled my own displacement
as a refugee child.
So as one person ...
As one person, what can you do next?
When you're confronted with something
that you know needs to be changed,
you have to find an entry point.
For me, that was mobilizing
a Jewish response
and then scaling that up
to the interreligious response in the US,
focused exclusively on Syria.
It's called the Multifaith Alliance
for Syrian Refugees.
And today, we have more
than 100 partner organizations.
(Applause)
I saw an opportunity to build bridges
while also saving lives.
And here’s how.
The southwest part of Syria
was very difficult to access
because it was surrounded
by regime forces.
That was a gap.
Israel shares a border
with that part of Syria.
And guess what?
It's easy to get aid into southwest Syria
from the Israeli side
of the Golan Heights.
That gave us something doable
with which to fill that gap.
All we needed was the how.
And that's why my colleagues
and I found ourselves
in clandestine meetings all over Europe.
We were making the case
that Israel should be used
as a staging area
for the outbound delivery
of international humanitarian aid.
We lobbied the UK Parliament,
the EU Parliament,
the Canadian Parliament.
We banged on doors in Congress.
We met with every level
of government in Israel.
And ...
We got nowhere.
But then it happened.
In September 2016,
the Israeli government launched
Operation Good Neighbor.
It was now official government policy
to open the border
so that aid from other countries
could be facilitated
and sent in to Syria.
So soon after,
once we were able to get
Operation Good Neighbor going,
soon after, enormous cargo
containers of aid --
many of them bearing goods
from Syrian organizations --
were being unloaded in Israeli ports
by Israeli soldiers,
sent over to the Golan Heights
and from there, our partners
on the ground in Syria
would pick up the aid
and distribute it to an area
with a population of 1.3 million people.
We delivered 120 million dollars
of aid this way.
We supported three medical facilities,
a bakery that produced 15,000 pitas a day.
The Israelis provided water,
fuel, electricity.
We shipped medical equipment, ambulances,
food, clothing, sanitary kits, medicine,
whatever else was needed.
And by working through local councils,
we were able to help stabilize
an entire region.
For two years, this was the only
part of Syria that worked.
But then, because of an incursion
by the regime and its allies,
that area was completely
taken over and destroyed.
But that did not stop us.
We expanded our deliveries
to other hard-to-reach parts of Syria.
Today we have delivered
nearly 245 million dollars in aid.
(Applause)
It wasn't easy
and it wasn't without hiccups.
But by working with these
unlikely partnerships,
we were able to help
more than two and a half million
war victims and still counting.
(Applause)
Now, here's the great news.
You don't have to go
to a war zone to do this.
I've applied my formula
in a bunch of other settings.
So let me share a couple
of quick stories with you.
Early in my career, 1971, to be exact,
I was living a life of crime.
Crime prevention, that is.
(Laughter)
I was also deeply immersed
in the women's movement.
So where could I make a difference?
My entry point was the New York City
Police Department.
Victims of sexual assault
were being very badly treated.
That was a gap.
The doable way to fill that gap
was to set up the first
sex crimes unit in the country.
Well, today we've got "Law and Order: SVU"
to tell us how it's done.
In fact, they've been telling us
how it's done for the past 23 seasons.
But back then, back then,
this was a new idea.
I've done the same thing
with large corporations.
When the new millennium was approaching,
the human resources field
was laser-focused on workplace 2000,
with diversity being a key goal.
But religion was very rarely looked at
as an aspect of workplace diversity.
Yet if you looked
at the changing demographics,
it was obvious that this
was going to be a big issue.
So that was a gap.
Another organization I founded,
the Tanenbaum Center
for Interreligious Understanding,
found a doable way to fill that gap
by guiding major corporations
in accommodating religious beliefs
in the workplace.
Well, it's been a long road to Syria
from my early forays
as a professional change agent.
But when I saw the Syrian tragedy unfold,
a biblical verse, Leviticus 19:16,
kept reverberating in my brain.
"Thou shalt not stand idly by
while the blood of your neighbor
cries out from the earth."
Well, that's why I got to work.
I hope you will, too.
Thank you.
(Applause)